former japanese prime minister shinzo
abe has been shot in the city of nara
after attending a campaign event two
shots are reported to have been fired
from a handgun with the second hitting
the politician in the back officials in
japan say abe is in a grave condition
the attacker who made no attempt to flee
the scene has been detained by
authorities
well for more we can now talk to
journalist sonia blaska who joins us
from the japanese capital tokyo welcome
to dw sonya what's the latest you can
tell us from this shocking event that
we've seen this morning
we've just heard something about the
motive of the attacker he actually said
that he wanted to kill abu because he
was
not content with abe and abe's politics
so there is obviously this this very
political motive there
we've also just had a press conference
by prime minister kishida who looked
visibly shaken
and at the moment they're trying to
figure out like what to do about the
elections and how this will all play out
because japan is supposed to have opera
house elections on sunday and i think
the attack can be seen against the
backdrop of that
so deeply deeply shocking of course for
for the japanese people um now you
mentioned there uh the motive from the
suspect tell us a little bit more about
the suspect what do we know about
well japanese media knew relatively
quickly who it was the the name is known
and he's 41 he's from nara so from the
city where the whole tragedy happened um
he seems to have
made
this gun like on his own or it looks
kind of um i don't know he put tape
around it maybe to to hide that it's a
gun
uh that's a bit strange
other than that um not much is known
there were these two shots um that hit
other in in the chest and apparently the
neck
um
yeah so these are the current uh
information the current um details that
we've got
abe was apparently able to talk with the
rescuers so that's some good news but
other than that we're still waiting for
confirmation from the hospital
now you were mentioning there that the
elections it's unsure um whether they're
going to actually take place on sunday
shinzo abe left politics um well left
his role two years ago but what was his
role on the campaign trail
well he was um speaking at various
events over the past couple of days to
support members of his liberal
democratic party
and also the the incumbent prime
minister kishida so
yeah
he is despite
officially stepping back from his post
as prime minister he's still very much
in the center of japanese politics and
and kind of pulling the strings uh
behind the scenes so to speak um also as
a member not a member as the leader of a
very
big faction within the liberal
democratic party
now shootings are very rare in japan
how shocked are the japanese public
with what happened in nara
extremely shocked
i mean i can't really say it in a
different way um there have been a lot
of
reactions coming in uh people condemning
this type of violence
this is not something that japan is used
to at all there have been very few
incidents of this kind of caliber in the
past
and
the question is also was there enough
security or not or how could he slip
past security so i think i hope we'll
get answers to these questions very soon
sonya blaschka in tokyo thank you
you're welcome
you